so as we continue let me say a few words
about the topic of our discussion for
for today many of you all of you come
well prepared for it and I will just
pull some strands together and then let
professor Kelsey speak to us and then
our discussions will follow first a few
comments about significance of fate
significance of fates in the globalized
world seems obvious today is the
anniversary of 911 and I thought it may
be actually good for us to stop for a
brief moment not simply to reflect about
significance of fate demonstrated in
that event but also to think about lives
lost but seven years ago a little bit
earlier than this time in the day
as Christians will probably say may the
light perpetual shined and then other
traditions might have different ways of
expressing their own wishes for the
departed but we are meeting on this day
right and the destructive power of faith
was obvious to all obviously faith also
has the power to inspire noble causes
and indeed not just normal causes
because it's but practices and policies
at the global level other case study
which we are examining in this course
Jubilee is an example of that but you
may ask is it really faith that's doing
all the heavy lifting in these two cases
and in similar cases as well you know
there are theoretical counter arguments
to that kind of a claim you know faith
many people might claim is epiphenomenon
it's derivative in the last analysis
faith explains nothing in the world
other things explain faith but faith
doesn't explain anything Mark's faith is
a sigh of the oppressed creature
Friedrich Nietzsche kind of met a
physical expression of resentment but
even from that theoretical critical
perspective the claim is not that faith
is not causal claim is not faith doesn't
cause ultimately anything right Marx
would say it's opiate for the people it
offers false consolation it does
something Nietzsche would say it is a
weapon in the hands of the week helps
them control powerful right so you've
got this effects of faith even from the
standpoint of somebody like nature or or
marks but in addition to these possible
theoretical objections even even the
practical analysis of what has happened
in 911 say may suggest well political
causes were more prominent and even if
it's true that these were dressed more
in a kind of religious garb for whatever
reason or at the economic level was
significant even if religion gave it
additional motivation something like
that can be can be said so that's a
criticism possible of faith as causing
something but maybe it's too strong
long maybe it will be wrong to put issue
in terms of an alternative either faith
or something else faith need not be the
sole cause or primary cause of events to
qualify as significant force and deserve
our attention indeed one might argue
that for such complex events as a 911
was and many others all mono causal
explanations are to be suspect in the
first place religious convictions it
suffices for religious convictions for
fades to be one among many significant
causes but then the question might be
well how important are they if they're
one among many are fades as shapers of
civilizations determinative for
conflicts of the future as Huntington
has argued or is faith or fades a
contributing element to events positive
negative whose main causes are
non-religious or even you can ask the
question our faiths able to steer
significant significant ways large-scale
processes such as globalization you
might even ask the question all such are
such processes steerable is it a word
well it is now can such processes be
steered at all or do we live as Anthony
Giddens has suggested in a runaway world
or our fates there simply to tweak one
or the other aspect of the processes in
one or the other direction now certainly
the focus of this course will not be
relationship of faith to the
globalization as a whole but the
functions of faith within the processes
of globalization now that's about
significance of faith let me now say a
few words about the ambivalence of faith
now we can grant for the sake of the
argument that faiths are significant but
how do we appropriately evaluate from
moral or practical standpoint that
significant and I think that there's a
number of ambivalences that can be noted
so I'll name them ambivalent
one two three and four for the lack of
better description right so ambivalence
one some consider faith the force were
good and some consider it as fais force
for ill force for good believers
especially right those who believe that
fates are in some ways divinely revealed
such believers would claim that at least
their fate if not any other are a force
for good many other folks who are not
believers I won't call them atheists
because that strikes me as to negative
of a way of putting things or even
non-religious people maybe humanists
maybe a go to term for those who are not
believers in the particular religion but
even such people may consider faiths as
high achievements of human spirit
achievements that sometimes malfunction
but achievements that are because they
have endured over long periods of time
achievements that are a force for the
good now you may flip the thing and take
the other side of the Aviva land to say
well faith is a force for real and
critics may argue that faith is by
nature irrational and irrationality is
in principle and always good even if it
might have immediate positive positive
effects or critics may argue that faith
is by its very nature violent maybe
partly because it's irrational but even
apart from it being irrational fate has
maybe fates great fates have at their
Center something like cosmic war for
instance other instances of such
explanation of the violent nature of
faith can be also undo adduced that's
the kind of ambivalence of faith from
two different sides looking folks
looking at what faith does but
ambivalence can be also identified as
people seeing in fades both force for
good and for ill and at the same time
some people may not agree that fates are
forced for both ill and good at the same
time if a tissue is something like the
very nature of faith or god forbid that
I use the word essence of faith in
today's academic
environment but something of the sort
what defines the very character of fate
right they might not agree that fades
are ambiguous in this sense and
ambivalent in this sense if we are
dealing about the very essence of it but
they may well agree that faith our fates
are ambivalent if we take into account
concrete fades as they are lived in the
world today if we take into account
lived experience of the people of faith
throughout their history and indeed
that's what we're going to be looking at
in this course so that's ambivalence to
ambivalence three is this ambivalence
stems from the fact that fades
themselves or particular versions of
faiths themselves they provide
interpretive lens by which to judge what
is happening in the world today take 911
I think it matters whether you share bin
Laden's religious convictions and
considers and consider all who disagree
as apostates and infidels for describing
before deciding whether the attack on
World Trade Center is to be described as
deplorable violence or just struggle
those perspectives matter from where you
stand or in trips of a Jubilee I think
there was a one comment in our
discussion sections which I enjoyed very
much by the way Jubilee it may matter
whether you are a scientifical in mind
that economist guided solely by
utilitarian principles or if you are a
religious person who believes that we
should feed the poor irrespective of the
consequences of that action for future
economic development it may matter which
on which side you are in in your
judgment as to whether Jubilee
initiative was a salutary thing or was
in some ways deeply problematic finally
fourth ambivalence there are internal
debates within each religion each faith
is not one stable thing and unchanging
things so as to be simply forced for
ill or force were good it has developed
over time it has variety of expressions
depending on large cultural environments
in which it finds itself and then the
very specific conditions limited
conditions in which faith are at the
given moment give also shape to two
faiths that's a rather complex account
of what individual faith is and that
creates its own ambivalences or each
faith is internally differentiated
indeed many people say that fades are
always comprised of collect rent
internally of traditions of argument
that go over periods of time and there
are significant debates that are raging
within various faiths who legitimately
speaks for traditions is the particular
interpretation true or false how does
the interpretation fit the larger shape
of faith or some of the fades basic
convictions so many debates that are
going on within fades and often you can
find because of these internal debates
between within fades that sometimes
positions of two faiths there folks of
who are members of two different faiths
who are closer to one another then the
folks who are members of a single faith
right precisely because these internal
debates which makes it possible also i
think for traffic to go between faiths
as that traffic and debate is going on
within those faiths so that's about the
ambivalence a complex character of the
ambivalence of faith now our task today
is to explore the significance and the
abilities of faiths